el día 10 de Abril de 1998 coincidiendo
con el viernes santo se firmó en Reino
Unido el acuerdo del mismo nombre que
ponía fin a más de tres décadas de
guerra interreligiosa y política entre
los separatistas católicos de Irlanda
del Norte encarnados en el grupo
paramilitar el ejército republicano
Irlandés el ira y los protestantes
unionistas con Reino Unido el acuerdo
fue firmado por los gobiernos de la
República de Irlanda y del Reino Unido a
quien pertenece Irlanda del Norte además
de ser refrendado por el pueblo de las
dos irlandes más de 3.600 personas
habían muerto en el conflicto para
analizar qué legado dejó este acuerdo y
cómo ha servido de ejemplo para otros
acuerdos de paz hablamos con José Rivera
González profesor de estudios
internacionales de la Universidad del
Sagrado Corazón en San Juan de Puerto
Rico señor González Bienvenido a France
24 antes de entrar a analizar el legado
de este acuerdo explíquenos Cuáles son
las ideas principales que atraviesan el
texto y cómo se consiguió llegar a La
Paz en un conflicto tan enraizado dentro
de un territorio muy pequeño
Claro que sí y muchas gracias por la
invitación el acuerdo de belfas y el
acto acuerdo de viernes Santo good
Friday agreemen como lo conocemos en en
inglés
trajo consigo algo que en ese momento de
lucha sectaria se veía imposible y era
traer distintas facciones dentro del del
de la del de Irlanda del Norte a la mesa
de las negociaciones para poder tratar
de tener un acuerdo que permitiera no
solamente la inclusión de las distintas
facciones en el proceso político sino
otorgarle relativa autonomía a la
provincia para autogobernarse eso
implicó que dentro de la mesa habían
enemigos jurados entre ellos
nacionalistas o o republicanos como se
le llaman y y un unionista en un momento
dado quienes estaban en la mesa de la
negociación eran los las facciones
moderadas de estas de estas de estos dos
sectores por ejemplo el partido
unionista del uster o y oster United
party y claro está el social democrática
en Label Party que era la la izquierda
nacionalista pro unificación de Irlanda
eventualmente el envolvimiento de de
Tony Blair como Primer Ministro recién
electo por el partido laborista el
Primer Ministro islandés en ese momento
y claro está el elenzo de Bill Clinton y
el envolvimiento de su enviado el
senador George bitcher fue lo que
entonces dio el último paso el paso
clave para incluir
a todos los partidos Incluyendo a chinfe
en las negociaciones y claro está el
acuerdo que se dio que que permitía
entonces esa inclusión la la los
derechos de todas las partes y claro
está la posibilidad de un autogobierno
y sin embargo ahora vemos con el brexit
y el nuevo estatus de Irlanda del Norte
con ese acuerdo con la Unión Europea
como en cierto modo el conflicto se
reaviva no puede ser esto un reflejo
quizás de que el legado del acuerdo es
más el letargo del conflicto que la paz
real la integración de los diferentes
actores
absolutamente pero también implica el
hecho de que la paz no llega
automáticamente una una vez se firma el
acuerdo hay que trabajarla a través del
tiempo en el largo plazo y evidentemente
y atestiguamos verdad que la el el el el
fin de la violencia o el cese de de la
violencia está ahí a través de este
último cuarto de siglo y que movidas
como la del brexit te impuso entonces en
una una frontera dura verdad lo que
llaman en inglés eh
trae consigo una serie de problemas que
pueden reactivar y reavivar el el el el
el el el conflicto por eso es que el
protocolo de Irlanda del Norte se firma
luego de las negociaciones del del
brexit y claro está el protocolo de Star
Mont para tratar de facilitar el
intercambio de bienes y servicios entre
la provincia el Reino Unido y obviamente
la República de Irlanda así de delicado
y Así de importante es la construcción
constante de la paz en esta provincia
que sufrió treinta años de violencia que
José Rivera quiero traer este acuerdo a
nuestra región América Latina porque es
conocida la influencia que ha tenido por
ejemplo en las negociaciones en el país
Vasco para que se consiguiera la paz con
el grupo terrorista eta se ha podido
quizás ver esa influencia también en el
acuerdo de 2016 entre el gobierno de
Colombia ahora esfar y las FARC o son
quizás idiosincrasias demasiado
diferentes es posible que en esta nueva
negociación con el eln un acuerdo como
el de viernes Santo puede haberse más
reflejado
la respuesta corta a tu pregunta es Pero
tienes razón las y las idiosincracias
son completamente distintas Pero hay
elementos en común estamos hablando de
facciones que están encontradas que
presumimos en un momento dado de
irreconciliable pero que debido a la
fatiga de de la violencia el hecho de
que la la comunidad no se mueve hacia
adelante en términos económicos y claro
está la presión pública y la valentía de
las partes políticas que se envuelven en
esa negociación es lo que entonces hace
posible un acuerdo tengo que recordarle
a toda la la la audiencia que estas
cosas no son fáciles y no se dan de
manera automática en el momento en que
se firma ese ese acuerdo de paz siempre
va a haber rencor en el caso de Irlanda
del Norte se liberaron personas que
cometieron enormes violencias que
cometieron asesinatos y esto creó un mal
sabor entre ambas comunidades se
liberaron prisioneros de Lira y se eh
También se del ejército republicano
Irlandés y se liberaron también de la
fuerza voluntaria del huster que son es
una facción paramilitar unionista Eso
quiere decir que que va a haber gente
transitando por la calle que
probablemente en algún momento quieran
eh quiere hacerse retribución pero es
importante que la ausencia de violencia
figure prominente en este tipo de
acuerdo sea en Colombia sea en Irlanda
del Norte sea en Sudáfrica sea también
porque los ejemplos también son variados
y ante y anteriores a este acuerdo Como
por ejemplo Los acuerdos de paz en El
Salvador y claro está en en Guatemala eh
Es decir la violencia poco a poco se va
desarticulando Pero no del todo tenemos
que recordar que muchas de estas de
estas situaciones incluyendo Colombia
incluyendo Irlanda del Norte mucha gente
no puede hacer la transición a la vida
civil y claro está lleva a la violencia
a otro extremo en este caso en forma de
gangas criminales o grupos paramilitares
que no se desmontan y que siguen
entonces eh campeando por su respeto en
el campo político y obviamente
comunitario y José Rivera González
estaríamos mucho más tiempo hablando de
este tema pero tenemos que despedirle le
agradezco que haya estado con nosotros
hoy en France 24 seguramente volvamos a
hablar de temas de paz aquí en la región
Muchas gracias Claro que sí cuenten
conmigo placer
sigan ya en France 24 porque enseguida
volvemos
[Música]